[Music]
the first ancestor of the Shang knew
named chonway was a descendant of the
great you the founder of the SHA dynasty
previous to the time of Yao and shun we
hear of a race called the mountain jiong
these were the hynnyín or who knew who
inhabited the northern regions and moved
from place to place
according to the pasturage for their
flocks and herds the bulk of their stock
consisted of horses oxen and sheep but
in the smaller numbers they bred
likewise camels asses mules horses
hybrids wild horses and hybrids of the
same moving their herds to find water
and pasturage they had no fixed cities
but dwelt on their rural patrimony
each family having its allotted portion
of land they had no written character
but performed oral contracts the
children rode on sheep and shot birds
and squirrels with the bow and arrow
when a little bigger they shot foxes and
hares the flesh of which they ate on
reaching manhood when able to bend a bow
they were fully equipped and mounted on
horseback
[Music]
in time of peace they hunted for their
living
but when harassed by war they cultivated
martial exercises to fit them for
invasion or attack which was agreeable
to their disposition the Tula troops
were armed with bows and arrows
the shorter with swords and spears when
successful in the contest they pressed
forward but on meeting with a reverse
they retreated and thought it no shame
to run away on gaining a victory they
showed no regard to propriety or equity
from the king downwards all ate the
flesh of domestic animals and clothed
themselves with the skins wearing the
fur covering over all the able-bodied
ate the fat and choice portions while
the aged ate and drank what was left the
strong and robust who held in esteem or
the old and feeble which Retd with
contempt when a father died they married
their widowed mother and when a brother
died it was customary to marry his widow
their names were not transmitted to
their descendants
[Music]
according to their laws he who drew a
sword a foot in length against another
was put to death anyone guilty of
highway robbery was deprived of his
family possessions small crimes were
punished with the rack and greater
crimes with death the longest
imprisonment did not amount to ten days
and all the prisoners in the country
only numbered a few individuals early in
the morning the shenyu the leader of the
Shang nu went outside the camp to
worship the Rising Sun and in the
evening he worshipped the moon in
funerals they used coffins and cases
containing gold silver and clothing but
they had no grave mount trees all
morning apparel several tens or even
hundreds of near dependents and
concubines were accustomed to follow
their masters funeral in undertaking any
military enterprise
they were always guided by the moon when
the moon was about full they would
engage in battle but when on the wane
they withdrew from the contest when one
beheaded a captive in battle he received
a goblet of wine and was allowed to
retain the booty captives were given as
slaves to their captors so that in war
every man was struggling for personal
profit they were clever at leading the
enemy into an ambush and then
surrounding them the eagerness of the
Scramble was like birds flocking to the
prey but when calamity overtook them
they were dispersed like scattered tiles
or passing clouds anyone bringing home
the body of a man slain in battle got
the property of the deceased
at a subsequent period in the north they
subjected the Huang you there hue she
the tingling the key Quan lung and thus
in the nation's the nobles and chief men
of the Shang knew then all submitted to
mouth tongue whom they looked up to as a
wise Prince the Han Dynasty having just
come into power sin the prince of Han
was moved to Tay and made his capital at
my yay
this city was forthwith surrounded by
the Xiong nu who took the place after a
vigorous of salt in the autumn of 201 BC
having secured the submission and
cooperation of sin of Han the Shang knew
marched south across the cow stream to
attack Tai un and went under the walls
of the capital Cao a the emperor of the
Han took up arms and went in person to
oppose them it being winter time what
with the severe frost the rain and the
snow twenty to thirty percent of the
Emperor's troops lost the use of their
fingers Mountain watching his
opportunity made an appearance of being
defeated and fled drawing all the hand
troops after him while the latter
eagerly followed up the pursuit Mountain
concealed his best soldiers and exposed
the weak and emaciated the Chinese
confident in their greater numbers held
three hundred and twenty thousand
infantry for the pursuit
callate with a detachment of these
arriving at ping Ching before the great
body had come up mount Tong immediately
brought into the field three hundred
thousand of his choicest cavalry and
surrounded the emperor's party at ptang
hill
for seven days all communication was cut
off between the Chinese forces inside
and those outside the circle the
enclosed party being thus deprived of
provisions
the Shang new horses on the west side
were all white on the east they were all
white faced Gray's on the north they
were all black and on the south they
were all Bay's reduced to extremities
cow day quietly sent a messenger to the
consort of the shenmue to seek by a
liberal promises to secure her influence
in which he was successful the consort
addressing Martin said why should two
sovereigns distress each other having
now got possession of the hand territory
the Shen you can never occupy it
moreover the Shen you sacrifices to the
spirits of the lords of Han now Mountain
having previously made an agreement with
Wang Wang and Xiao Li two generals of
sin the Prince of Han and having been
long looking in vain for their arrival
at length began to suspect some plot
between them and the Chinese hence he
ceded the more willing to his consort
suggestion and made an opening at one
corner of the cordon caught a then
ordered his troops to take their full
complement of arrows pointing outwards
and so passing straight out at the open
corner they joined the great body of the
army mountain then withdrew his forces
and the Chinese troops ceased all
hostile movements while Liu Qing was
sent to make a treaty of peace and
friendship with his young knew
subsequently sin of Han being a general
under the Xiong nu together with child
II and Wong Wong several times broke the
treaty about that time parties of the
Shang know frequently on meeting the
Chinese general that the head of his
troops would tender their submission on
which account Mountain kept up a
succession of raids on the country about
Tay this was a cause of much anxiety to
the Chinese and eventually that the
Emperor to adopt the notable expedient
of sending a princess of the Imperial
house to Mountain for his consort
the lady Jung Joo was selected and
conveyed to the home of her new Lord by
Leo King it was hoped that the issue of
this union might be more imbued with
Chinese susceptibilities and tendencies
and thus be more easily brought under
control in pursuance of the same policy
the Chinese sent yearly presence of raw
and woven silk wine and food thus aiming
to cultivate Chinese tastes among them
and on each occasion the return on bond
of peace and Amity was renewed so that
for a time there was a cessation of
mountains incursions